I'm a Cardinals fan so just hit Harry
for us right now because Kyler Murray
seems to be you know uh he's got paid
thank God yeah hopefully now it's behind
us because they put the uh claws in his
contract where he has to study that's
racism
that's pure blatant racism
uh you know what
I loved NFL with me it's some moral
things I can't even really stand with
that the black man can't even really
have to like DeShawn
he he's a different thing but I think I
think DeSean just loved Lamar all these
black quarterbacks and stuff like that
like they trying to give them little
Clauses and stuff like that right right
right that's that's racism I think that
um
DeShaun Watson is probably just a single
man I kind of don't even want to talk
about him well I was just disgusting to
me for it I don't even you know he might
just like a rub and tug
he might just love to get the tug you
know what I mean hey when uh what's the
owner of the Patriots
Robert Kraft Robert Kraft
they got photos of him leaving he got
too much money
I don't need Meek Mill coming for me
but Robert Kraft
no but listen Robert Kraft there's
[ __ ] pictures of him leaving the rub
and tug
they couldn't they could they didn't
even suspend him let me tell you a funny
story
crazy story so
uh at the Grammys we sit next to Robert
Kraft
uh we tell them we Falcons playing we're
from Atlanta
drug taxis whatever is holder he's like
283 diamonds on it because we lost 28
and 28-3 oh that was no no you guys were
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
his homie just pulled it out Robert
Kraft did that
that's his homie back to the woods I was
like yeah
wait wait wait so he was traveling it
wasn't even on his phone dick it was on
Deck so he just had a guy holding the
Super Bowl rings I'll never forget it
bro imagine that's your gig yeah like yo
your job 100 000 a year is I give you
six bands or six six figures of you just
gotta carry the Rings and when some
random piece of [ __ ] sports fan comes up
to me pull them boys out Rob I caught
him Rob like my boy Rob looked at us he
was like
close this out